[Music]
what do you have in store for tonight's
performance well I have my little dance
crew along with me which is always nice
to have on stage so you honestly just
feel a little bit different out on stage
without the other boys there so I mean I
can see Niall in the distance now when I
tell you so I'm missing it it's
comforting I mean the danceOn and I like
it needs the dance and if it takes your
mind off things it's nice
you mentioned Niall he's on stage right
now how has it been reuniting with him
on the jingle balls war I think I mean
we played a bit of PlayStation is thing
in my hotel room in San Jose I got a lot
complaints of my feet on the bed I'm
sorry about that
and then yeah it's became hung out for a
little bit but it's just so nice to see
him I mean I don't know when you see
someone the unseen rages and you become
the same person you were when you would
I don't know it's great interesting any
chance of you guys collaborating on
stage at all I mean I get all been
singing about slow hands also asking me
all day when are we gonna do a Christmas
song from you or a holiday song I mean
someone show me like an NSYNC song they
did they did the other week and I was
like I'd love to do a Christmas song I
don't want to ruin any of the old
classics you know not ruin a song I love
anything now I'm a dancing bamboo touch
cheesy
whereas I want to do some add lights to
an honest Christmas song maybe it's your
first holiday season as a father
any new traditions that you're looking
forward to starting well I used to go to
Disneyland when I was a kid a lot with
my parents you still go to Florida every
year and I like the idea of taking him
when he's maybe about six that's not way
off yet but that's like my dream what
are you guys doing for this holiday
season you and the family well I have a
little nephew that she's been born as
well who's younger than bear baby Ashton
and so it's gonna be very baby full
house I imagine the happiness and love
arounds gonna be amazing so plans for a
full album in 2018 I am working I kind
of changed my mind in a few things so
I'm still kind of working towards it but
I don't know it's different these days
things aren't very commentary' kind of
release music whenever you want so I'm
kind of abusing that fact a little bit
and trying to find the best songs
possible so if you were to release what
would you want to have it sound like
you're going with that like still treat
our soulful soulful fun soulful pop you
know enjoyable and
and you know maybe a little bit hip-hop
in there as well I'll let you go can you
pick a question out of our Santa
snapback who do you plan to kiss under
the mistletoe this season that's a good
one
I'm gonna have to say my missus and my
little boy as well bless
[Music]
you